do you know the movie 2001 A Space
Odyssey of course yes so you must be too
young to have seen nothing came out
obviously uh yeah I remember
you saw when he came out
yeah yeah 50 years ago 60 what was it 60
uh it was in the 60s yeah that's right
and it's still a classic it's still
probably
the greatest AI movie ever made yes yes
I agree uh one of the great space movies
I've ever made yes so well let me ask
you philosophical questions since we're
talking about robots exploring space do
you think HAL 9000 is good or bad so for
people who haven't watched this computer
system makes a decision
to uh basically prioritize the mission
that the ship is on over the humans that
are part of the mission
um do you think Hal is good or evil if
you want to be probably in that context
it was probably good but I think you're
raising what is of course very much uh
active issue in everyday life about the
extent to which we should
um entrust any important decision uh to
a machine and there again I'm very
worried because I think um if you are
recommended for an operation or not
getting parole from prison or even
denied credit by your bank
you feel you should be entitled to an
explanation
it's not enough to be told that the
machine has a more reliable record
um on the whole than humans have of
making these decisions you think you
should be given reasons you could
understand and and that's why I think uh
the present societal Trend to um
take away the humans and uh leave us
um in the hands of decisions that we
can't contest uh is a very dangerous one
I think we've got to be very careful of
the extent to which AI which can handle
lots of information actually makes the
decisions with our oversight and I think
uh um we can use them as a supplement
but to take the case of um uh radiology
and cancer
um I mean it's true that the
radio radiologist hasn't seen as many uh
X-rays of cancered lungs as the machine
so the machine could certainly help but
you want the human to make the final
decision and I think that's true in most
of of these instances but if we turn a
bit to the short-term concerns with uh
robotics I think the big worry of course
is the effect it has on people's
self-respect and their labor market and
I think um my solution would be that we
should arrange to tax more heavily
the big International conglomerates
which uh use the robots
um and use that tax
to a fund
decently paid dignified posts
of the kind where being a human being is
important above all carers for old
people teachers assistance for young
gardeners in public parks and things
like that and if the people who are now
working in mind-numbing jobs in Amazon
warehouses or in
telephone call centers
are automated but those same people are
given jobs where being a human is an
asset
um then that's a plus plus situation and
so that's the way I think that we should
benefit from these these Technologies
um uh take over the mind-numbing jobs
um and uh you use machines to make them
more efficient but
um
enable
um the people
so displaced to do jobs where we do want
a human being I mean most people when
they're when they're old
um they're rich people if they have the
choice they want human carers and all
that don't they they may want robots to
help with some things
empty for bed pans and things like that
but but they want real people and uh uh
and certainly in this country I think
he's worse in America
um the the care of old people is
completely inadequate and it needs us
more human beings to uh help them cope
with everyday life and look after them
when they're sick and um uh and so
um that seems to me the way in which the
money raised in tax from these big
companies should be deployed so that's
in the short term but if you actually
just look the fact is well we are today
to long-term future in a hundred years
it does seem that
there's some significant chance
that the human species is coming to an
end in his
pure biological form there's going to be
greater and greater integration to
genetic modification than a cyborg type
of creatures and so you have to think
all right well we're going to have to
get from here to there yeah and that
process is going to be painful and that
you know how there's so many different
trajectories that take us from one place
to another it does seem that we need to
deeply respect humanness and Humanity
basic human rights
human welfare like happiness and all
that kind of stuff no absolutely and
that's why I think we ought to try and
slow down the application of these human
enhancement techniques and Cyborg
techniques for humans for just that
reason I mean uh that's why I was a
leading through people on Mars let them
do it but but uh yeah for just not
reason but they're people too okay
people Mars are people too yeah I tend
to you know but they are very poorly
adapted to where they are
right that's why they need a
specification whereas where adapted to
the Earth quite well so we don't need
these modifications we're we're happy to
be humans living in in the environment
where our ancestors lived so we don't
have the same same motive so I think
there's a difference but I agree we
don't want uh drastic changes probably
in in our lifestyle um and that indeed
is a worry because some things are
changing so fast but I think um I'd like
to inject a note of caution
um if you think of the way uh progress
and one technology goes
um it goes in a sort of spurt it goes up
very fast and then it levels off
um let me give you
two examples well the one we've had
already are human space flight
um at the time of the Apollo program
which was only 12 years after Sputnik
won
um I I was alive then and I thought it
would only be 10 or 20 years further for
the were Footprints and Mars but as we
know for reasons we can all understand
um that was instead Remains the high
point of human space exploration
um that's because it was funded for
reason the superpower rivalry I choose
public expense
um but uh let me give you another case
um civil aviation
um if you think of the change between uh
1919 when that was all clock and Brown's
first transatlantic fight to 1979 the
First Flight of the jumbo jet it was a
big change
but it's more than 50 years since 1969
and we still have jumbo just more or
less the same so that's an example of
something which developed fast and
things ever and to take another analogy
um and we've had huge developments in uh
mobile phones but uh I suspect the I
boned the iPhone 24 may not be too
different from the iPhone 13. and
because you know they they uh develop
but then they saturate and then maybe
some new innovation takes over in
stimulating economic growth yeah so it's
that uh
uh we have to be cautious about being
too optimistic and we have to be
cautious about being too cynical I think
that is well optimistic expecting the
question I mean do we want this very
rapid change right so first of all
there's some degree to which
technological advancement is is
something is a force that can't be
stopped and so the question is about
directing it versus stopping it or so it
can be sort of slow we'll take human
space flight it could be have been uh
footprints on Mars if if America had
gone on spending four percent of the
federal budget on the project after yes
upon uh but the reason so there were
very good reasons but
um and we could we could have had
supersonic flight but Concord came and
went during the 50 years
by the reason it didn't progress is not
because we realize it's not good for
Human Society the reason it didn't
progress is because it could make uh
sort of from a capitalist perspective it
couldn't make uh there was no short-term
or long-term way for it to make money so
for me maybe it isn't but that's the
same mistake it's not good for society
I don't think everything that makes
money is good for society and everything
that doesn't make money is bad for
society right that's a that's a
difficult
that's a difficult thing we're always
contending with when we look at social
networks it's not obvious even though
they make a tremendous amount of money
that they're good for society especially
how they're currently implemented with
advertisement and engagement
maximization so that's the constant
struggle of you know I agree with you
there's many Innovations are damaging
yes yeah yes uh well but I would have
thought the supersonic flight was uh
something that would benefit only a tiny
Elite sure a huge expense and
environmental damage that was obviously
something which they're very glad not to
have in my opinion
yeah but perhaps there was a way to do
it where it could benefit the general
populace if you were to think about
airplanes wouldn't you think that in the
early days airplanes would have been
seen as something that can surely only
benefit one percent at most of the
population as opposed to a much larger
percentage there there's there's another
aspect of capital a system that's able
to drive down costs once you get the
thing kind of going so the you know we
get together maybe with taxpayer money
and get the thing going at first and
once it gets going companies step up and
drive down the cost and actually make it
so that blue collar folks can actually
start using this yeah and sometimes that
does happen that's good yeah so it's
that's again the the double-edged sort
of uh human civilization that
some technology hurts us some benefits
us and we don't know ahead of time we
can just do our best and and this gap
between what could be done and what
we can actually decide to do
yes in the term you could push forward
some developments
um faster than we do